uh when I was in high school I I didn't
study any computer science I know uh
many Israeli students do like a a b like
a final examination um in areas of
technology that are adjacent to computer
science and cyber security um I actually
wanted to be an Aeronautics um engineer
I wanted to build airplanes and um
airplane related stuff like a spaceship
I don't know what I wanted to do back
then um but I kind of stumbled into
computer science when I studied uh some
computer science classes throughout tpot
uh the program that I attended uh within
the IDF um and I realized that you can
basically write things with your
keyboard and solve problems uh which was
quite awesome to me so welcome to
20-minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of Make A Wish Israel and Tech
to peace and and is in proud
collaboration with secret cord Ventures
J Ventures Riverside FM Fusion VC birth
R Excel J impact leap Google for
startups and hippo and in media
partnership with
[Music]
ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders I'm so
excited and honored to have these 20
minutes with you so thank you for
spending this time with me how are you
thank for having me uh I'm great um all
else considering everything is is great
yes well we we are recording this
episode at a difficult time H our
country is in is in war um and but but
over these 20 minutes we're going to be
celebrating entrepreneurship and we're
going to be celebrating curiosity and
inspiration so I'm I'm looking forward
to this Beacon of life
over these 20 minutes and lat your um
your background is awesome you said out
right we we have a lot of shared
passions and shared interests and so I'm
obviously very objective H but I'm I'm
excited to hear a little bit about your
journey you're um an important figure in
the cyber security landscape H with with
an incredible background from the IDF to
palto networks to today your your own
startup Eureka security I'd love to go
back a little bit to your the early days
of your of your interest section to the
world of cyber security how did that
happen you know where are you from um it
happened almost by accident uh if I have
to be honest uh when I was in high
school I I didn't study any computer
science I know uh many Israeli students
do like a a bot like a final examination
um in areas of technology that are
adjacent to computer science and cyber
security um I actually wanted to be an
Aeronautics um engineer I wanted to
build airplanes and um airplane related
stuff like a spaceship I don't know what
I wanted to do back then um but I kind
of stumbled into computer science when I
studied uh some computer science classes
throughout tpot uh the program that I
attended uh within the IDF um and I
realized that you can basically write
things with your keyboard and solve
problems uh which was quite awesome to
me so ever since I was 18 I was drawn
into this world of problem solving
through software um and later on
understanding that you can um diver how
software behaves to make it do the
things that you wanted to do um and
through that into cyber security so
that's how my passion to computer
science and cyber security started uh
needless to say uh so many years later I
don't want to mention how many uh but
I'm still very passionate about problem
solving and cyber security and the
combination of those two things is what
I dedicate my life to and so um your
excitement around not only software but
but cyber security more more Bradley
tell me a little bit about that there's
a lot of different areas in which you
can employ skills through software to
make an impact and solve cool problems
what is it about the cyber security
landscape that really sparked your
interests so I think for for many you
know many of us um in the Israeli cyber
security Community especially
entrepreneurs um have started in uh
units in the IDF that are very much
focused on cyber security
um I can't really talk about what what
that means or what we've done back then
uh but we've solved amazing challenges
throughout software and throughout code
um and that has lit up a spark that I
think many of us in the cyber security
Community share around doing impossible
things or things that are considered
impossible uh through through software
through cyber security um I think the
and the combination of that for me with
the understanding you know I've I've
grown up in the early 2000s so really in
the in the um climax of The
technological Revolution um I I remember
you know my first phone was a regular
Touch phone like with keypads and
everything um and we've seen that
development of how technology is now an
uh a part of every aspect of our lives
so the combination of the passion to the
technology itself and problem solving
with the understanding that um the cyber
world the technology is where all of our
lives are in where bank accounts are in
where all all of our social connections
are in where our work is in um led me to
strive to to secure that that way of
life for us um so so that that is what
I've been doing phenomenal I love that
um and I think that one of the one of
the interesting aspects I guess that
that fascinated me about cyber security
is that it's it's it has um often I
think a more a faster pace of of the
evolution than perhaps a lot of other
Industries because of the nature of the
tug-of war play and because of the the
market dynamics that that enforce this
quick action reaction play and so I
think that and perhaps for competitive
people and and I can I I have a feeling
that you're a little bit competitive H
just from uh the the first four minutes
of our conversation um well tell me a
little bit about um your experience at
PTO networks that and then leading into
the founding of Eureka security
yeah um so maybe before I dive into that
and kind of gives context to that I
think in relate uh in relation to what
you just said I think there are two you
know for people in general there are two
driving factors there's the overall
vision of what you want to do with your
life and then there's the day-to-day so
I think you know the overall vision is
that you know what what what is what is
it that I want to focus my life what I
want to dedicate my professional career
too and that part we talked about and
then obviously on a day-to-day basis
there is the kind of you you you can
really rest you always have to keep up
with new innovation and new technologies
and new competitors and that makes the
day-to-day that much more exciting um
and that actually brings me um into my
career um at pal networks um so I
started out within the IDF in very
technical roles I was a software
developer team leader and group leader
later on uh but when I wanted to better
understand the uh the Dynamics of an of
an actual Market um I decided to switch
into product management so my f first
role after the IDF after leading a group
of a few dozen uh software Engineers was
actually to become a a a product manager
one of one of many in the team um and
they wanted to do that because
understanding that dynamics of the
market of what you choose to focus your
efforts on on the competitive landscape
and so on is really what I wanted to Now
understand I felt like you know Tech
would be Tech wherever you go but it's
that understanding of the market that I
was missing um so I was very fortunate
to join palal networks um at a time
where it was it was rapidly growing um I
joined pal networks about a year after
its first AC acquisition in Israel so
with the Tel Aviv office I was the 80th
employee um to the day of this recording
I think there are about a thousand
employees in the palet Network's offices
and that's before a couple of new
acquisitions uh that yet to announce um
so the it was the time of this huge
growth both from an organizational
perspective and also a few uh very
significant transformation
in terms of the areas of focus Propel to
networks uh first and foremost the
transformation within the product that I
was a part of um I was uh within the
input UT security product focused very
much on on exploit prevention and kind
of very Advanced things to the Next
Generation antivirus into EDR into what
is now known um as xdr so various
revolutions and Transformations on that
side uh a significant transformation
from on-prem to Cloud both in terms of
the focus of what needs to be protected
as well as how it's need to be it needs
to be managed and I and again I was very
fortunate to be a part of that I I I
kind of think of about that like sitting
on top of a balloon that keeps uh um
keeps being uh keeps growing and kind of
being able to grow with it I love that
that that's so cool and it must have
been so awesome being as part of this
rocket ship and seeing it grow and and
not all if you know it's such a both a
rocket ship in terms of of human capital
and and growth of a company but also
technologically I mean really being at
the at the bleeding edge of you know
these these complex technological
Endeavors and and um so um you can sense
a little bit of jealousy from from my
hand so it it sounds really really great
hiring the uh founding of Eureka what
happened there um so needless to say you
know I I I I very much loved working at
Pala networks so leaving Pala networks
um after six years requires you know at
many many points in time um I was asked
about or offered uh different uh options
to explore um but you can imagine the
level of conviction that I needed to get
to uh for me to decide to make that move
um and that level of conviction was was
the way I got to that was kind of uh I
would say two two main factors um so to
understand uh uh the first one maybe
just to give you a bit of context around
what I did what was my last role pal
networks uh so I spent six years at Pala
networks four out of those were very
much focused on kind of the evolution of
endpoint security as I said and then for
the last couple of years at pal networks
I was I was actually leading um and
creating what is what was then known as
the threat hunting Service uh so again
just a bit of context for the listeners
threat hunting is a methodology in cyber
security where you actively search for
any existing threats within the
environment that were not identified by
the variety of tools that are out there
so you need to sift through a lot of
data and identify anomalous activities
and suspicious behaviors and so on um
larger organizations like largest banks
of America would would um have threat
Hunters working full-time for them but
not many organizations can do that which
is why Pal's networks decided to go into
that space awesome so I was leading this
service and we were sitting on a pile of
data like a ton of data uh that we were
able to to look through to identify
those threats and you can imagine how
valuable that data uh was for other
teams in the organization uh machine
learning engineers and data scientists
and product managers and product analyst
and the researchers everyone wanted to
use that data to gain insights but pal
networks being a very secure company um
has limited access to that data quite
significantly so if someone wanted to
ask a question as it relate to that data
they needed to ask me so I would
literally get scripts over email uh with
someone you know hey can you run the
script for me to run in and out process
I would R the result and then a day
later I would get a fixed script because
they wanted to shift the uh the
algorithm a little bit and that drove me
crazy um so I turned to Asaf which is
now my co-founder uh a very good friend
of mine we've served together back in
the IDF and have worked together at TH
networks W he left uh to work at
Microsoft and I talked to him and I told
him St how do you how do you do this at
Microsoft like you also have a lot of
data you also want uh this data to fuel
the organization but you're struggling
to do so because I'm sure Microsoft is
as secure if not more than pal networks
and he said honestly we have the same
issue um so the combination of having a
problem that we were passionate about
that we felt firsthand and we thought
could make a big impact with the uh uh
combined with um assaf's desire to solve
it with me uh was what led to the uh
creation of Eureka uh we both decided
this would be a great opportunity for us
to work together again after not working
uh for together for a few years and that
led to uh Eureka being created
incredible and so first time CEO right
and co-founder you've had a lot of
experience now in different complex
environments and and different um
different
experiences how what has what has the
experience been like you know in the
early days so you know what what shifts
did you realize you were making as now a
leader and as a CEO what surprised you
what didn't surprise you so I think that
there are two two major ones one is more
more on the product and technical side
and the other is more on kind of the
company building side yeah um so on the
technical side we kind of assumed and
you know just being a part of
organizations like the IDF and pal
networks obviously not small
organizations not ones that prioritized
business and and and uh agility um over
other things we kind of thought that the
problem we were seeing is the problem
that many organizations would have and
the first real ation we had very early
on in the first few months of kind of
the validation process was that most
organizations actually have the opposite
problem they allow too much access to
data too much data to be used too much
data to move around different
environments for different use cases
that their problem is controlling that
um so obviously we kind of shifted the
way we we uh positioned the the problem
statement and the way we built the
product to not just enable organizations
more flexibility but rather to allow
security teams to Control the Chaos that
has been created uh by that flexibility
um and that is in many ways you know you
hear about startup the start day one
they have one solution or one idea and
two years later they're doing something
completely different uh we are not one
of those we're uh we I could basically
use the same deck that I used uh month
three into the startup as we do today uh
year two uh or starting year three um
into our startup um so that that's from
a product perspective from a company
building perspective I think you you
know a lot of us especially in Israel a
lot of us come into entrepreneurship
from a very technical background um I I
I was actually I had the privilege of
having like uh a bit of a broader
background given that product management
works more with customers work with
customer success and support and
marketing so I had these interfaces um
into other organizations I knew what
their job was I understood what it means
but I never created these organizations
and I never managed them um so I think
you know um the uh it required me to
develop this new sense of curiosity not
just towards the technical stuff but
also towards the uh surrounding
functions it is now my role as much as
any other um and to to find the right
mentors along the way whether if if they
are employees in the company or if
they're Founders that have gone through
this journey before to be able to rely
on and learn from it's not something
that you you you're born with no matter
how significant your background is there
are some things you're better at so
right before we get more into the
product and the offering um from from
from a values perspective and the
culture that you're building out you've
had experience um with with different
environments that and we talked about
sort of this the the the passion the
Curiosity for the field but also the um
the types of thep the types of problems
that you yourself enjoy enjoy solving
what what was important for you in in
building the culture of Eureka and what
were some of the key elements that you
identified either early on or now that
you're saying well this is this is the
place I want to lead and work at this is
the type of team that is going to to be
able to own up to to to this challenge
that we've
undertaken yeah um so I think you know
there's there's the things that guide
Asaf and myself when building the teams
the team and then there that lead us
when we think about how how we do we
include team in the decisions and what's
happening with the company uh so in
terms of building the team um obviously
everyone are looking especially for this
core initial team of a startup for uh
great people who have uh strong
technical skills that have a good
understanding of the space we're in um
and again uh we are very fortunate to
come from backgrounds where these people
you know we've worked with these people
we know most of the team we we knew
firsthand when they joined the company
um but what was also important for us
and that required us to go a bit outside
the box is to to have a team that is
diverse um and that comes from from
backgrounds that are not just similar to
ours um so we we are almost 50/50 from a
gend perspective which was something
that was important for both Asaf and
myself to be able to achieve and as you
as you might expect it's not that we
came from organizations that were uh
5050 um so so it did require us to to be
more um focused on on these hiring goals
for example um and then from an internal
perspective we we are strong Believers
in transparency and visibility um just
just as one as uh just to give one
example every board meeting we have um
between a day or a week after we
basically do like a rerun of the board
meeting internally for the team because
they are a stakeholder in the company um
and there's no reason for them not to
understand where we're at what's working
what doesn't work you know other than
than uh seeing personal details of other
employees we want them to understand
what's going on with the company where
headed what are what are we doing well
towards that goal and what can we
improve on um because the best way to
achieve those goals is to have them be a
part of them and make sure that they are
tuned towards the same uh the the same
Target phen I think that's um that's
very very cool and so I and I love that
we've uh I I love that we've uh spent so
much of the time talking about you know
your journey and the and the um the type
of organization You're Building because
I think really that's perhaps the the
most important pie here but I don't want
to leave without also getting a good
understanding of of what it is that you
actually do today with Eureka and the
product and and and the offering so so
share with me a little bit about what
what urea is is all
about yeah so I we talked before about
the challenges of dat so you know it
these challenges aren't just unique for
companies as large as Microsoft or palet
networks um with uh the cloud Revolution
and transformation that has happened
over the last decade and the data
transformation that is still happening
with the variety of AI tools that are
available for different organizations
and now even more so with llm uh models
becoming available organizations are
storing more and more data in um higher
levels of sensitivity and in a larger
variety of cloud uh cloud and data
storage Technologies and that creates
quite the complexity for cloud security
teams um you need to be able to develop
the level of expertise you need to
understand where data is you need to be
able to classify the data and understand
what it is is you need to be able to
unravel all the different access
mechanisms to understand who actually
has access to data and which entities or
third party applications or service
accounts and so on so our goal is really
to to support these organizations in
their journey to support the business um
and to eliminate that the that inherent
trade-off that they have between
securing the data and allowing it to be
used so we say allow the data to be used
will'll make sure you have the right
guard rails around the data to keep it
thank you so much thank you um I I'm
leaving this conversation more inspired
than I than I came into it with which is
my personal fulfillment from doing this
so I really appreciate it I'm I'm
excited to see where you're heading H
with yri and with every other Endeavor I
think you really embody the type of
entrepreneur that I wish to be and you
embody I think um a really awesome part
of sort of the startup ecosystem in in
Israel but but in general so so thank
you very very very much and and best of
[Music]
luck